all right live stream a lot of sexual
assault allegations going around going
to talk about the latest ones although
they may already not even be the latest
these are from a few hours ago
Minnesota Democratic senator Al Franken
accused of impropriety and I think that
this will be a good opportunity to sort
of maybe have a broader conversation
about some of these allegations and and
so first let's start with Al Franken Al
Franken was accused by LeAnn Sweden of
actions that he took during a USO tour
in 2006 to entertain troops and as she
told the story Frank and forcibly kissed
her and then was in a picture seeming to
grope her breasts over some kind of uh
or at least where her breasts would be
behind what looked like some kind of an
army vast protective vest of some kind
while she was sleeping and there's a
photograph of that that that's out Al
Franken immediately responded saying I
don't remember the rehearsal for the
skit the same way the rehearsal being
where Al Franken is accused of forcibly
kissing Lea aunt Whedon but I send my
sincerest apologies to LeAnn as to the
photo it was clearly intended to be
funny but it wasn't I shouldn't have
done it
and Al Franken supports the incident
being sent to the Senate Ethics
Committee which apparently is going to
happen we will see ultimately what
happens there and what comes with that
and in addition to this LeAnn Sweden has
accepted Al Franken's apology she says
the apology sure I accept it yes people
make mistakes and of course he knew he
made a mistake so yes I do accept that
apology there's no reason why I
shouldn't accept his apology
people make mistakes I'm not calling for
him to step down that's not my place to
say that
so this is listen let's go through this
in pieces right number one for those
people who were saying I was never going
to talk about this I I talk about all
these stories whether it's a Republican
or a Democrat that's accused of this
that or the other thing I talk about it
I have a long history of talking about
it and I don't I don't think that
there's any period I don't think I have
to say anything anything else about that
I think that there there are some
differences between all of these recent
cases right so we never want to write
off any particular incident of sexual
assault groping impropriety or whatever
we never want to write it off as not
important or irrelevant in any way but
we also do need to realize that the Bill
Cosby situation is different than louis
c.k is different than Roy Moore is
different than Al Franken whatever here
we have an al Frank and a reaction that
is different from the reactions we've
seen from others which is to say what I
did was wrong
and in addition to that supporting an
investigation into what he did and
letting those in charge of that ethics
committee decide ultimately what his
fate will be the other difference I see
is that the person in question here has
accepted Al Franken's apology and the
dynamics of that also appear to be
different than some of these other
incidents that that we've seen which of
course none of these are excuses for
what Al Franken did there is no excuse
for what Al Franken did and he seems to
be clear in saying that that there there
is no excuse and he's not making any
excuse so we will see what ultimately
happens and there's another element to
this which is if and how this will
impact the Alabama Senate race of Roy
Moore because what we've seen happen
there Al Franken is a sitting senator
Roy Moore wants to be a senator and we
we can we can speculate about what might
happen if Roy Moore wins that Alabama
election despite being accused now by
six women of a broad range of a very
strange behavior and and possibly
illegal behavior in some in some cases
and that we've heard from Mitch
McConnell that there's the possibility
of not ceding roy more expelling him
from the senate if you were to win but
that's all hypothetical and quite
frankly I don't know that Republicans
are actually going to do that on the
other hand in Al Franken we have someone
who is a senator right now and that does
create a different scenario and there
there can be an investigation of the
sitting senator and we will see what
ultimately happens I listen alfrid
context anthony Weiner's politics I
agree with them doesn't mean I defend
any actions that they took and and with
Anthony Weiner in particular you would
hear allegations from some on the right
that oh look at look at Democrats
defending Anthony Weiner for the same
type of behavior that they criticize
Republicans for doing I didn't see any
Democrats defending Anthony Weiner I saw
them mostly say I either agreed or
disagreed with his politics or I thought
he was a good debater or a bad debate or
whatever and what he did was absolutely
and totally deplorable period and the
guy doesn't deserve to hold public
office as a result so I you know don't
don't fall for the talking points
because it's really important to point
out double standards when they exist but
it's also important to identify when
someone is alleging a double standard
and there actually isn't one right so
don't don't fall for that and we'll see
what ultimate ultimate Lee happens with
Al Franken I'd be interested in hearing
through the super chat if people feel
strongly one way or the other about what
they think is going to happen with Al
Franken and on that note before we
continue talking about it let me welcome
everybody who's with us to the live
stream if it's your first live stream
that the coolest thing about the live
streams is that they're live as the name
suggests you can send me questions or
comments I'll read them react answer
them if it's a question respond if it's
a comment through super chat and through
stream labs
perché at is the dollar sign towards the
bottom of the YouTube chat dialogue and
stream labs.com slash the david pakman
show is an alternative to super chat
which we get more of the money when you
use stream labs YouTube I believe takes
30 percent and stream labs I think takes
like three percent so we get more of the
money number three new members and
patrons during the live stream will get
thanked use a patreon I believe is down
for maintenance I was getting emails
from people saying they were trying to
pledge on patreon and that it was down
for a scheduled maintenance so you may
not be able to do that but very exciting
news when it comes to membership we've
had this Jenga thing going on in the
studio for more than a week now and the
the gist was as follows for every two
patreon contributions I would make one
Jenga move and then when the tower
ultimately fell we would just double the
number of moves I was able to make and
create a coupon code based on that so if
I was able to make fifteen moves we
would come up with a 30% membership
discount code I was able to make 29
moves before the tower ultimately fell
today and this is mid fall from today's
broadcast program I think this clip is
going live on YouTube soon members
already would have seen it 29 moves I
was able to make so we set up the coupon
code gen 258 je nga 58 and I put it down
in the description for the live stream
and it's there and you can you can use
that if you want 58 percent off which is
really a pretty damn good deal and you
will still get just as emphatic of a
thank-you from me if you use the Jenga
58 coupon code and by the way the first
thing I would watch if you become a
member is today's full broadcast show
which we upload around 4 o'clock for all
of our members the tower falling the
Jenga tower falling it's quite a moment
it's very very loud it startles me Pat
was actually almost in tears and
everybody everybody was really surprised
and taken aback so that's going on
anyway and I'll we'll do some thank-yous
a little bit later also the David Pakman
show is now on Steam it steam it is a
very cool platform that is blockchain
based and
the great thing about steam it is many
of you know that we've been struggling
since March 31st because of this YouTube
D monetization thing steam it is almost
like reddit but people earn money based
on upvotes
so you don't have to spend any money on
steam it but if you go to steam it calm
slash at sign
David Pakman link is in the description
you can just upload our content and we
earn money as a result of that so it's
building quickly we're already at almost
a thousand subscribers after only a week
there and it is a cool thing so check
that out steam it calm slash at-sign
david pakman show if you have any
question about how to spell it just
check in the description because I am
linking to it right there okay back to
the Al Franken story what I listen the
most curious thing that I think it
exists here because it's it's another
allegation against someone in a position
of power is if this will impact the Roy
Moore election and there's one poll that
has Roy Moore down twelve one poll that
has Roy Moore up two there's a lot of
weird stuff going on with the polling
maybe to create complacency among
Democrats so that they just won't vote
in Alabama I don't know the answer I
don't know the answer but it would be a
disaster if Alabama voters decided to
vote for Roy Moore because Al Franken is
accused of something because really you
have to evaluate Roy Moore on his merits
right and I already can see a situation
where the there is going to be an impact
here and I am not I'm against the
oppression Olympics and I'm against the
ranking of sexual assault allegations
but there is no question that what Roy
Moore is accused of that is is on a
completely different unit is in a
completely different universe than what
it is that Al Franken has said he
participated in again which he's
apologized for and and Lee ant Whedon
has accepted the apology for right it's
not a defense it's drawing a very clear
distinction in the same way that
forcible rape is different
then verbally saying something to a
woman as she walks by neither is good
we're not celebrating either but we do
recognize that not all of these
incidents are the same and I think that
it is important to do that let me go to
we're starting to get questions and
comments rolling in let me see what I
want to start well let's start with
super chat facts night has sent a $5
super chat asking have I thought about
trying to upload on youtube alternatives
like vid me and [ __ ] shoot we looked at
vid me we were on vid me for a little
bit and we're currently sort of like on
a hiatus from bit-bit vid me I guess I
would say I'm I would consider going
back there maybe well there's a lot of
different things going on with their
platform [ __ ] shoot I'm not familiar
with but we are now we are putting all
of our content or a lot of it on Steam
it that's the one we're using ste MIT
/at sign David Pakman and you can check
that out there and I think that it is
something you will enjoy I think that
that will be a good thing and speaking
of things you will enjoy I went back on
the Jesse Lee Peterson show and this is
this whacked-out show that exists on
Newsmax and I guess it's a radio show as
well and I was on a while ago and the
first time I was on it was an absolute
and total disaster but I did take the
interview seriously because I thought
yeah but I take every interview
seriously and I've been invited however
they've been bugging me to go back on
for some time and I went back on
yesterday and I effectively got myself
kicked off I don't really know how else
I can describe it but I took it
seriously insofar as you know I showed
up on time and that was it but Jesse Lee
Peterson kicked me off and we've
uploaded that interview it's on our
YouTube channel you can check it out now
you can check it out after the live
stream is over it goes I was scheduled
to be on about 20 minutes and it ended
up going I think like seven minutes
because
Celie peterson was so displeased with
how i was communicating with him during
the during the interview
it is absolutely hilarious and we
included in the clip that's up on
youtube after I get kicked off of
Newsmax TV by Jesse Lee Peterson
yesterday his he and his producers start
having a conversation and it's very
clear that his producer does not see me
as as bad of a guy
as Jesse Lee Peterson sees me and they
seem to be getting into this weird
back-and-forth someone tweeted me that
they're not they wouldn't be surprised
to see Jesse Lee Peter or just Jesse Lee
Peterson fire his producer over those
disagreements I don't think that'll
happen but it is very very very funny so
check that out it I had put aside a half
hour because they told me we need 20
minutes and I always a lot a little bit
of extra time and after just a mere
seven minutes after seven minutes he
kicked me off and it was absolutely
everything everything that I could have
could have imagined it could be okay let
me go through some of the different
questions that are popping up in the
regular chat I don't want to do this
elitist thing where I will only answer
questions and read comments from the
paid super chat & stream labs let's
let's see what questions people have
here let's see someone's saying they'd
be okay with me sexually assaulting them
well I would never do that she was
faking asleep the woman in the picture
yeah there's people saying that in the
picture that Al Franken that has been
released of Al Franken that Al Franken
is not actually making physical contact
with the woman's breasts and that there
were rumors that she was pretending to
be asleep listen no one's denying that
it is the way it's being reported Al
Franken has apologized and Lee aunt
Whedon has accepted the apology so I
don't I don't know how much we need to
really dig into that
let's see someone asking if I'm gay I am
not gay not that there would be anything
wrong with that what else do we have
here I guess there's someone jocular
jellyfish who was already banned but
seems to be back not sure how that works
but that's that person is really
annoying and congratulations to Lauren
Thomas are great moderator for getting
another
another uh what would we call it another
swiping the bedpost so to speak another
notch in the old belt with another solid
ban Aaron Davis is asking whether I know
what's going on with the drunken
peasants debate with sargon of akkad or
isn't I know him Karl Benjamin yeah so I
could I do have an update on that I
guess it was a week or two ago I
received a Twitter message from TJ Kirk
who also goes by the name amazing
atheist asking me if I would be willing
to debate Sargon of Akkad I said I would
be willing but please reach out to me
via email so we can set up the logistics
he did reach out via email and I said I
basically just would want to know number
one what is the time of this the
duration of this debate because I these
days I'm just so busy I don't want to
get into one of these three hour debates
and TJ said it doesn't have to be three
hours he also suggested a bunch of
different topics and some of the topics
aren't really topics I cared a debate
like for example brexit was on the list
I'm not a brexit expert I'm not
passionate about brexit so really what I
wouldn't be the right guy to debate Carl
Benjamin about brexit so we're trying to
fine-tune topics and again it's been
several days since I heard from from the
amazing atheist so that's what's going
on that's the status currently Aaron
let's see someone commenting that they
were number 25 in our Jenga challenge
and they were sure it would fall on
their move but it didn't it didn't what
else here do we have in the comments and
questions people telling me that the
picture is nonsense Al Franken wasn't
touching the woman people referencing
some of Jesse Lee Peterson's phrases the
children of the lie and the dirty
woman's March what else do we have is
there a link to the original Jesse Lee
Peterson video James maple ask you know
I don't have the link if you go to
youtube.com slash the david pakman show
and under search just type Jesse Lee
Peterson it'll come up there's only a
couple videos that come up when you
search for that people saying you don't
have to minimize what Al Franken did in
order to demonstrate that it's not as
bad as what Roy Moore did yeah I agree I
mean there again I'm not minimizing what
Alfred
but I think that it would be weird to
pretend like what Al Franken did is the
same thing that Roy Moore is accused of
or what Bill Cosby is accused of or
whatever right I mean it just it's just
not and plain and simple okay we've got
a contribution over at stream labs.com
slash the david pakman show $15
contribution from Jason who says merely
love your show David well thanks Jason I
appreciate that on that note I haven't
updated this for a while the top donors
of all time at stream labs.com slash the
david pakman show during the live
streams Eric Patterson still holding the
top spot with two hundred and fifty four
contributions dollars in contributions
Clark one two three four in second place
with just under a hundred and thirteen
dollars and the user who goes by the
name of rappleyea in third place with
$100 with $100 and then in terms of the
number of contributions cloth one two
three four in first place with forty two
contributions Christina in second place
with forty one and then Eric Patterson
tied with I think one other person maybe
not know Eric Patterson and third place
with seven contributions so a lot of
action a lot of action going on over at
stream labs I am getting a oh and let me
also let me let me deal with Vladimir's
question here
Vladimir Alexandrov has sent a $3 stream
Labs contribution David if you had to
interview Sam Harris what kind of
questions would you ask him what sort of
disagreements do you have with his views
thank you I am NOT a scholar of Sam
Harris so I wouldn't be able to
concisely tell you where I agree and
disagree with Sam Harris but I think if
I interview him I would be very
interested in getting sort of some more
specific and and defined statements from
him on some of his views regarding Islam
and terrorism and you know I think that
there's lots that Sam Harris says that I
believe he's right about which some on
the Left tend to dis
I also think that there is stuff that
Sam Harris says that is a little bit off
but I'm not a scholar of his of all of
his work and if I were to interview him
and I would love to in fact I've invited
him on the program multiple times but
he's never agreed to come on so far I
would absolutely love to do that and I
would spend a lot of time researching
and really there's so much that we could
talk about and I would really enjoy
doing that if you want to suggest
politely to him on Twitter that he'd do
an interview on the show I would
absolutely love to have him so that that
would be let's try to get that going
people have tried people have reached
out to him and it has not gone well
enough I guess he hasn't been on the
show
Steven anter has sent a $2.00 stream
lapse contribution can you do more
economics related debates with Ben
Shapiro I'm willing I don't know if Ben
Shapiro is interested in being on the
program the last time Ben Shapiro was on
the David Pakman show our show was much
smaller but Ben Shapiro was also much
less well-known and he might be too big
for the David Pakman show at this point
every once in a while we'll exchange an
email because of course all Jews know
each other right I mean obviously but
the topic of him being on the program
hasn't come up I'm willing to have him
on I think it would be interesting I
don't know that he's interested Brian
sent a dollar stream lab's contribution
what's your thought on the stupid little
smirk jeff sessions had during the
senate hearings this week i think a lot
of people have tweeted me about the jeff
sessions smirk he had a hearing
yesterday again heard of the day before
where he just lied endlessly about trump
russia contacts and what he knew and
when he knew it and he did have this
smirk I believe that the smirk is a sort
of smirk of complicity where he knows
that he's answering questions in a
deliberately either overly specific way
to avoid line or an overly vague way to
avoid obvious lying I guess I would call
it because he did lie right I mean it
was still still pretty damn obvious
that's what I make of the Jeff Sessions
smirk during that
and it wasn't a new thing in prior
hearings I think it was the same one
where Democratic senator camel Harris
kind of destroyed Jeff Sessions he had
that same smirk when he was answering
questions in this particularly it's like
a combination of smug and coy I think
those are the best adjectives I could
use to describe it my interpretation is
he knows he's bullshitting and he thinks
he's being clever using very particular
and specific language but I don't I mean
I wouldn't say it's not fooling
everybody anybody it's probably fooling
a lot of people but it didn't fool me
and that that's what I that's what I
attribute it to let me do a couple new
member thank-yous the Jenga tower fell
today on the show and because we got to
29 Jenga moves before the tower fell we
created a 58 percent coupon code you can
get a 58 percent discount off of
membership so where you could type I
voted 17 for a 40% discount you can type
Jenga 58 for a 58 percent discount just
through the end of the weekend and I
want to thank Jeff Withey Jeff Withey
has signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership during the stream rich boskie
i hope i'm pronouncing that correctly or
maybe it's Bosh I'm not sure rich that
part I'm clear on thank you for signing
up at david pakman.com slash membership
Joseph Tucker has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership Thank You
Joseph very much appreciate it and Brett
Osborne Brett Osborne has also signed up
and a lot a lot of new members Eric Phan
xania
Eric Phan Taniya thank you as well for
signing up very much appreciate
everybody who has been signing up
we had our Amazon affiliate link cut off
a couple weeks ago and we had YouTube ad
pocalypse oh it's been a tough year bit
this is our best year I've said it
before this is our best year by far in
terms of audience growth crushing it but
because of D monetization on YouTube and
the Amazon
debacle financially it's been a tougher
year so it's great that people are
signing up and you can use the Jenga 58
coupon code through the end of the year
through the end of the weekend I'm sorry
not through the end of the year okay
couple other comments from the regular
chat people saying I should interview
Michael Wood jr. I recently did
interview Michael Wood jr. someone
asking me my thoughts on Jason Kander
for 2020 no clue who that is and it's
way too early to talk about 2020 in my
mind some people still confused about
the crazy hair episode so let me explain
that people are referring to this people
referring to this so the crazy hair
episode was when we started our patreon
fundraiser I said if and when we get to
2,000 patrons I will do an entire
broadcast show with my hair uncontrolled
I guess we would call it without taming
it in the way that I typically do with
various products and industrial solvents
and different things and we eventually
got to 2,000 as you can see we're
actually up closer to 2,100 now although
patreon is down for maintenance I'm not
able to pull up the exact number so I
did it I I kept my word and I did it and
this was a particularly weird moment
that Pat was able to isolate and it has
become the calling card of the crazy
hair episode and that's that there's
really no more explanation than that
Allah I got I got the funny this the
finest thing happened so this people
that might find this interesting
the day I had my hair that way we
recorded our audience questions segment
and in that segment that particular week
there was a question asking me to weigh
in on the Sam cedar versus what's the
other guy's name Sam cedar versus I'm
blanking on the guy who Jimmy Dore Sam
cedar versus Jimmy Dore where am I on
that and Sam sent me an email
and it just said I caught it it was
something like I caught the clip about
Sam and Jimmy are you doing something
new with your hair mad scientist maybe
and I had to explain to him because Sam
had no idea about the entire thing that
was going on I had to explain to him oh
no I was just doing it because of a
fundraiser thing and I think that that
that calmed Sam down a little bit he was
getting a little worried I think for my
sanity he thought maybe YouTube D
monetization had really gotten to me
really gotten to me in some way ok major
announcement I am finally ready to
announce to you today that Monday and
Tuesday the race and IQ investigation is
going to be published ok part one on the
Monday show part two on the Tuesday show
getting us into Thanksgiving in a really
strong way it's about 30 minutes long in
total it'll be two 15-minute parts
well not exactly two 15-minute parts but
roughly it'll be it'll be a total of
about a half hour really great work by
producer Noah Ferguson on this one it is
a long piece it was a detailed piece so
I think you're going to like it we do
address historical attempts to link race
and IQ we do talk about the bell curve
and the resurgence of the bell curve
recently partially because of that
appearance by charles Murray on the IO
is it Charlie I always get the the IQ
guy is it Charles Maurice or something
else Marie I think it's Charles Marie
his appearance on the Sam Sam Harris
program created a big stir we address
all of that okay really good piece my
only concern and I I don't have a
problem admitting this my only concern
is that because it's a big topic and
there's a lot of science required to
understand it I'm a little worried that
people are going to tune out because
it's a complex thing right there's a lot
of science to explain but anyway that's
going to be on Monday and Tuesday it's
gonna be great
really really great piece and we
got a lot of other stuff we're working
on as well jane womanpower has sent a
ten Canadian dollar super chat so glad
these allegations are coming forth it is
devastating and horrific it I guess she
means it is a devastating and horrific
situation but a necessary one women in
my circles here in NL Canada are
certainly feeling a revolution for big
change I do think that it's a good thing
that we are seeing these allegations
come forward because part of the problem
around this topic is the level of stigma
that exists for people to go public with
what happened to them and if for no
other reason than trying to distinct
that this is really good and by the way
if we can get some sexual harasser Zout
of positions of power or at least
prevent them from getting into positions
of power in the first place I think that
that's a good thing right who could
possibly be against that
unless there's just so many people in
your constituency whatever constituency
that might be who have these skeletons
in their closet I think that it is good
and I completely agree with you
completely agree with you Jane and you
know you you often you will always hear
from people allegations or not evidence
and you know we need to see what a court
eventually decides and the statute of
limitations has expired on a lot of
these things you're not going to see a
court decide or judicata knee of these
many of these circumstances my instinct
is given the amount of stigma stigma
associated with coming out and going
public with these allegations combined
with the reality that particularly if
it's been a long time there's really no
benefit to these women to coming forward
in these ways and you could say well
with Roy Moore there's a benefit because
they might want to prevent him from
winning a lot of those women were
Republicans and
it doesn't make any sense it doesn't
pass the sniff test I my instinct is to
believe accusers and even Jeff sessions
it's crazy that I'm quoting Jeff
sessions he said it in a more coy way
but he meant it in a more coy way
there's nothing that makes me doubt
these accusers not I've not seen
anything that would call their
believability into doubt plain and
simple and and so I agree with you Jane
this is a good thing and and I'm curious
as to how deep it's all going to go
because I think before it's all said and
done it's going to be it's gonna get
much much worse gigantic has sent a $5
stream Labs contribution stream labs.com
slash the david pakman show gigantic
says david have you always been this
savage on twitter i only just started
paying attention to your twitter feed a
month ago and i love it when you retweet
the hatreds yeah so i'm taking a little
bit of a different approach on twitter i
have had i I learned the tactic of
retweeting hatreds from the late great
alan colmes i had the pleasure and
really just an honor of getting to know
alan colmes personally when i was living
in new york city he came to my studio I
hung out at Fox News radio when he was
doing his show and just just the nicest
guy and it was really sad to hear of his
passing not that long ago feels very
recent although I although I know it's
been months maybe even longer at this
point and he told me that he does this
great thing where he just retweets
hatreds and it just creates drama and I
do like doing that that I've been doing
for a while the new thing I'm doing is I
am being a little bit more aggressive on
on Twitter and people seem to be liking
it so one example is let me just look at
a couple of my tweets here there was one
particularly funny one that I thought I
thought was actually pretty clever that
I came up with there was some crazy
trumpets I don't even remember what the
guy was doing why can't I find this one
so really funny tweet man it is just
Twitter's very very slow tonight what
day was it November 13th I don't even
know
I tweeted one guy uh yeah there's this
there's user named Colin rug Colin rug
with two L's and two g's and he let me
pull up his profile he is a Christian
proud Donald J Trump supporter
conservative student and politically
incorrect and I don't know how I came
across him but I sent him a tweet saying
hey Colin rug are you this unhinged due
to a lack of intelligence or a series of
small strokes and people seem to like
that one people people did seem to like
that one I also have been correcting
some people on Twitter I think it's
important to be accurate and I've made
this mistake in the past Roy Moore has
not been accused of pedophilia and I
think it's important for us not to use
that word when it's not the right word
pedophilia is a sexual attraction to
prepubescent children and being the
fourteen-year-old that duh that Roy
Moore tried to date who knows what the
hell he was doing we have no reason to
think that she was prepubescent so
therefore it would not be pedophilia its
child sex assault right because it is
someone that is younger than the age of
consent so I think that that is
important but anyway yeah you can follow
if you want to see all this drama going
on on Twitter I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
and I think I'm only going to become
more belligerent as the Donald Trump
administration continues so that's
something to look forward to Vladimir
Alexandrov has sent a $2 stream labs
contribution David some time ago I
called him to recommend you to get
binoculars instead of getting a
telescope what you wanted to get did you
end up buying one observational
astronomy is awesome I remember you
leaving that voicemail Vladimir I have
I'm still interested in getting into
observational astronomy and and I'd be
interested actually in getting into
Astro photography living in Boston it's
tough because there's just so much light
pollution and I haven't gotten some some
binoculars yet I should I'm worried that
I'm not going to be able to see that
much in Boston just because of the light
pollution like when you hear that Mars
will be visible I was able to go onto
the the roof of my building and you know
I saw a red red dot in the sky
but you really can't see that much here
and but yeah I'm I'm interested I'm
interested and I haven't gotten it yet
Eric s has sent to five Canadian dollar
super cheddar why do you associate with
kolinsky when he clearly misleads and
Miss represents most on the right and
only debates weak right wingers well
listen I don't know what you mean by
associate with Kyle kolinsky like we're
friends friendly you know that not we
don't hang out he's in New York I'm in
Boston we used to hang out when I was in
New York we text every once in a while
we email every once in a while you don't
I mean it's just as a general thing you
don't have to agree with everything
people do in order to have a friendly
relationship with them I mean I'm
involved in a possible new venture here
in Boston with someone who is a good
entrepreneur and is pretty conservative
I mean they didn't vote for Trump but
they're they're relatively conservative
actually several people I'm in touch
with in Boston about possible projects
and you know it's I don't know exactly
how to answer the question but I don't
know what kind of Association you mean I
mean I'm not involved with the Young
Turks anymore and he stole I believe
part of that network and that's that I
don't know what else to say about it
Shane winter Shane winter has sent a
five-dollar super chat I am a triple
threat patreon membership and super chat
yeah triple threat or david pakman show
all-star is another term I apply to
people who are members patrons as well
as super chatters and and on that note I
actually should do a couple other new
member thank-yous the Jenga tower fell
today so we created the coupon code
Jenga 58 because 58 is twice the number
of Jenga pieces I was able to relocate
before the tower fell Jenga 58 gives you
a 58 percent discount off of membership
santos gonzalez has just signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership and I
really appreciate that
also Michael Davis Michael Davis has
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership normally members pay $6 a
month or 60 for the year okay with the
58 percent discount you instead pay now
I forgot how much
is how much is $6 minus 58% 2.52 cents a
month or 25 dollars and 20 cents for the
entire year that is a really really good
deal it's only good until the end of the
weekend the coupon code is Jenga 58 I'm
just saying I would do it I think this
is a great time to become a member
théo H sent a $10 super chap until today
Al Franken was my hero but he took
responsibility and apologized didn't run
from it unless other women come out
people change right I am NOT going to
minimize what Al Franken did but there
are many circumstances here that make
this far less disturbing than what Roy
Moore is accused of than what Bill Cosby
is accused of Kevin Spacey etc etc Al
Franken in the picture that was released
you know is it a comedy picture was the
woman really asleep or pretending to
asleep was he really touching her or not
I don't think it matters because Al
Franken has admitted that what he did
was wrong that he thought it would be
funny and it wasn't ly aunt Whedon has
accepted his apology and as of now Theo
there's no indication that this is
something al franken has any kind of
track record of but doesn't mean once is
okay but it is drastically different
than hanging out in a mall trying to
pick up fourteen-year-old girls right
which is what Roy Moore is accused of
the d2j bug has sent a $5 super chat now
I am going to have to create more
Martians because of my astro my
observational astronomy I'm not sure but
cool yeah Martians are good JH wh
Goodall has sent a 5 euro super Jack if
it was a country like Burundi or
Slovenia I wouldn't care but as the US
is the most powerful nation on earth I
am very concerned by what is going on
well I'm concerned too but I don't know
if you mean the sexual-assault stuff or
if you mean the Trump being President
stuff I'm not exactly sure what which
one you're referring to but there's no
shortage of really concerning stuff
going on in the United States so yeah I
agree with you but more clarity might be
useful because I'm not
exactly sure what what you mean let's
take a look at some of the regular chat
here good to see what's going on there
um let's see
pedophilia is a fascination with
children and the way the law stands is
at under-16 you are picking straws David
no I don't I don't think so I really
don't think so I think that this is an
important distinction it's not any
better what Roy Moore is accused of is
no better if it's not pedophilia but if
you google pedophilia which I did
pedophilia is a psychiatric disorder
where an adult or an older adolescent
has a primary or exclusive sexual
attraction to prepubescent children okay
if you are attracted to a post-pubescent
fourteen-year-old girl it's it would be
illegal its child sexual assault to
pursue that individual we can make all
sorts of different judgments about it
but it is not pedophilia and we open
ourselves up as progressives to
criticisms and I saw a bunch of them
Ferren cousins from Ring of Fire put out
a tweet about about Roy Moore in it used
the word pedophilia and he was just
getting crushed and and you're gonna get
you're you're gonna the message will be
lost sometimes if we make mistakes like
that so I think it's important we don't
need to call it pedophilia for it to be
really bad and and I that that's just
the reality let's see what other
comments we have here um people talking
about evidence for who knows what David
uh let's see what else we have Viva Hate
reott mail hatred mail yes people love
hatred mail I love hatred mail as well
people loving the new the big deals for
the new members that's a great thing
Jenga 58 is the coupon code people glad
that I'm being honest people saying the
Young Turks push a white hatred
narrative I don't know about that I've
not noticed that but I don't really
watch anything I plead you and I did
David but I don't know if he did donate
money if you're gonna donate money to
mr. Pakman donate some for the Puerto
Rican charities that need your donations
are you trying to divert
are you trying to divert donations away
from us that's not
but no but yes of course support
worthwhile charities absolutely let's
see Jack is asking whether I give a
discount for disabled people yes it's a
58 percent discount and the coupon code
is Jenga 58 and it's also available to
anybody else that wants it but
absolutely big big discounts for
disabled people okay what's the plan
through the end of the year next week is
Thanksgiving here in the United States
so we will do a regular Monday show with
part one of the race in IQ video we will
do a regular Tuesday show with part two
of the race in IQ video we will do a
Wednesday show that will be the format
of the Friday show okay so instead of
audience questions and live calls and a
classic interview on the Friday show
next week we're gonna do it on the
Wednesday show because that's going to
be the end of our new shows next week
and then Thursday and Friday we're going
to be off for the Thanksgiving holiday
and then we will be back then we will be
here sort of the normal schedule that
last week of November and early December
and then the last week of the year
basically we're gonna go right up to the
December 22nd and then the Monday after
that is Christmas and we're taking
Christmas off not because I celebrate
Christmas not because of anything other
than that it is a federal holiday and we
tend to take federal holidays off and
we're gonna take that week off the last
week of the year as we often do
particularly with the holidays kind of
overlapping with two consecutive
weekends and then we'll be back on
January 2nd so it's gonna be a great
great wrap up to the year it's been one
of our best years in terms of audience
growth we surpassed 400,000 subscribers
on YouTube we started the patreon thing
and all of that all of those things are
going really well it's been a tough year
when it comes to YouTube's the
monetization at one point we were down
99% in terms of our revenue off of
youtube and and we've started to recover
there so it's been a good year but but
also a tough year people asking when my
college lectures are going online
the plan for that's a lot of work to
produce those so when we get to 2500
patreon patrons we are going to record
and start uploading my 12 long-form
college lectures I'm teaching a class at
Boston College this semester on
epistemology critical thinking media
literacy etc and there's about 12 75
minute lectures that I could sort of
pull material from and do and the the
fundraising goal is 2500 patrons okay
when we get to 2500 patrons at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
which i think is still down for
maintenance today we will be producing
those okay so if you're interested just
make a note to make a contribution on
patreon when those when those come back
up gigantic has sent a five-dollar super
stream labs contribution did you ever
end up contacting a scroll past it did
you end up contacting the authorities
regarding that weird hatred who would
laugh like a maniac at 3:00 a.m. and
make 30 consecutive calls never met a
weirdo hate reott in real life never
made a hatred in real life through the
show I've met lots of conservative
lunatics in real life we you know I'm
not gonna say what we did with that I
think just in general it's better not to
it might have even been a mistake to
play that voicemail let me just put it
that way and not say anything else about
it
Yesenia Moreno has sent a dollar stream
lapse contribution how do scientists
define Hispanic how do they get an
average IQ score for Hispanics do people
mean mestizo yeah so Yesenia you're
right on the money when it comes to some
of the issues that we're going to be
tackling in the race and IQ piece part
of the issue is that race
you often hear these two sides on race
race is a social construct or races very
specific definitions of something
biological and the truth is that race is
a biological construct it is not a
social construct in the sense that the
perception of race has real impacts in
society but biologically there aren't
particulars that
this is a black person or this is a
Hispanic person and we talked about this
in the race in that Q video I won't go
through the entire thing now but the
definition of Hispanic is a whole
interesting thing that's affected me for
a long time because I was born in
Argentina grew up speaking Spanish moved
to the United States so by many
definitions
I am Hispanic but at the same time
ethnically my family I did my DNA test
I'm 97% Ashkenazi Jewish meaning Eastern
European Jewish many families before
World War two left Europe and came to
the United States
Ashkenazi famish families and they are
there's no question that they're
considered white in the United States
ethnically I'm no different than them
but my family went to Argentina that's
where I was born
I in a Hispanic culture and then moved
to the United States does that have any
bearing on my race for the purposes of
IQ am i part of the Hispanic IQ average
or the white IQ average doesn't really
doesn't not really clear it doesn't
really matter is the truth and that's
part of why the entire race and IQ thing
is pretty bogus and we're gonna we're
gonna talk about that in detail in the
in the piece next week great great
comment there okay I saw one other one
come through here on stream labs or no I
did not actually it's on super chat
Jane womanpower sent a $5 super chat
sell prints of your big hair a tag line
after your show name that's interesting
I wonder if we can get an artist to
cartoon a Phi or maybe to like Andy
Warhol my big hair thing probably a
higher resolution one than this that
would be interesting I wonder what a
good artist could uh could turn that
into good idea we'll look into it
let me also say thank you to Linda
crombie Linda crombie has signed up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership and because the Jenga tower
fell today you can use the coupon code
Jenga 58 in the coupon code field and
save 58% off of your membership very
very exciting stuff
that's it for today's livestream I've
got to go to bed